i want to flow right out of this
into this idea of well can we do better
than just getting it roughly okay can we
do something more precise and that's
where we introduce this idea of
pearson's correlation coefficient so
this is a double-sided piece of paper
you're going to need both sides and
you'll need a ruler as well
we want to answer this question about
you know when we said something might
have a strong correlation or a moderate
correlation or a weak correlation or no
correlation right what we want to do is
better than just these vague words we
want specificity we want numbers that we
can use to compare and that number that
we're interested in is called pearson's
correlation coefficient now there are
these three key questions that i want us
all to know like you can calculate
pearson's correlation coefficient the
calculator will do it for you okay
but i'm actually not interested in you
guys being able to calculate it i mean
i tell a lie i'm a little bit interested
because you will need to calculate a few
times but the calculation is not the
important part a machine will do that
for you in the future right
these things though no machine can do
for you you need to understand what's it
doing what is the aim or purpose of this
correlation coefficient
how does it do that and what does that
even mean these are the three questions
i want to i want you to leave from here
with some good answers when you go home
and maybe you know whoever's at home is
going to say hey what did you learn
today and you're going to answer peace's
correlation coefficient and they're
going to be like what
and your answer to their what will be
this okay like you're not going to tell
them how to calculate it okay
so by the end of this i don't know it
might take about 15 minutes let's see
how we go these are the things i want
you to be able to answer successfully
now as you can see down below in the
second half of this page to answer these
questions those three like the the what
and the y and all that kind of thing we
need two different objects we need to
technically define
what that coefficient is pierce's
correlation coefficient and we need to
technically define this vague idea we've
been talking about the line of best fit
we're going to do both of those okay
i'm just going to warn you ahead of time
you can see i have the formula hidden on
here you're about to write it okay but i
just want you to make a caution over
here on the left right notice i said we
need to understand the coefficients
formula we are not going to memorize
this formula
and in fact after like this week you are
probably not even going to use this
formula and you're thinking to me mr why
are we learning it then if we're never
going to use it and if we're not
memorizing it the answer is
you can't explain what the correlation
coefficient is without knowing what it's
doing okay so don't freak out when i
show you this formula write it down but
it's not here to be panicked about like
oh my goodness i'm gonna have to use
this thing in the future you're not it's
so that we can understand its inner
workings are you ready
here's the formula
now you're like okay now i understand
why he gave us a long prologue right
because as soon as people see that
they're like i'm just i'm just gonna
pack up and go home now right you never
have to use this formula like we never
expect you to say like ah here's some
data go ahead and do this okay
but i can't explain to you what the
correlation coefficient is without
looking at all the pieces of this thing
okay so what we're going to do is we're
going to step slowly through it and you
can see i've left all of this space
around
in that table
so that we can talk about the different
parts of the formula
and explain what each of them does
i make this nice and big for myself so i
can see all right
so
um you can signal to me that you've
finished writing the formula when you
put your pens down
um because i know it's it's a mouthful
um r is the uh it's the
pro numeral of choice i guess when we
talk about um the correlation
coefficient i don't know why they didn't
just use c for correlation because they
reuse letters all the time but i mean c
is used for constant i suppose so it's r
and they didn't even use p for pearson
but who knows
actually i have a guess as to why it's r
but we'll get to that a bit later i'm
not sure maybe you can look it up and
tell me
and then you get a mixture of
greek and
english letters let's see if we can step
through this most of the pens are down
which is fine you can pick them back up
i just wanted to get an indication when
you finish writing
let's step through this one at a time
the first thing is this big greek letter
here that you can see appears three
times can anyone tell me what is that
greek letter
it's uh okay you've gone straight to the
meaning the meaning is sum but the
reason why is it's the greek letter
sigma it's a capital s basically and
it's s for sum what we're doing is we're
adding up a bunch of values okay so this
means sum
because we are adding up values whatever
this whenever you see this sigma it
means whatever comes after that you're
going to add up a whole series of things
okay so this formula
is the addition of a lot of different
things
what is it adding okay let's look over
here on the right hand side
you can see a bunch of uh pieces of
notation they come up multiple times
right with these bars over the top now
you've encountered this before when you
see x bar that means
it means the the ah now this is
interesting we're in statistics right
the bar over the top actually can mean a
bunch of different things depending on
context in statistics
it means the average it means the mean
right you've got one for x you've got
one for y why do i have two different
means
kind of data is this again it's
bivariate data two variables two means
okay let's go ahead and write that down
these are the means
for your two different variables in this
case we're just generically calling them
x and y
you've got the means here and then you
have
an x and a y that has nothing to do with
the mean okay what does this represent
well if i go back to let's go back to
desmos here
these are the x's and these are the y's
you have many of them you might have 8
you might have 80. you might have 8
million each of those data points has an
x it has a y so now you can see why
there's a sum there's different x's and
y's hiding underneath here and we're
just going to have to work out or a
calculator is going to have to work out
a particular x take away the mean a
particular y take away the mean there's
one thing and then do it again and again
and then add all of them up that's what
this uh that's what this sigma indicates
okay
all right now tell me you think about
this right
x
a particular x
take away
the average for x
what is this telling us
hmm
you subtract well let's actually let's
think about this right um i'm guessing
the mean height for this class is
somewhere around 170 centimeters that's
just my guess okay just because i've
like stood roughly next to you and some
of you guys are well i'm 178. so i know
some of you taller than me some of you
are shorter than me there's more people
shorter than me here in this class not
by a lot but you know outliers sometimes
okay so if i call this 170 do you all
know what your height is
yeah okay so i want you to mentally
calculate for yourself what your your x
which is your height take away x bar
the mean
for you is right
now say for me 170 i'm actually just
going to drop this down as an example
right
if i said 178 which is my height take
away 170 which i'm just putting out
there is the mean height okay
that gives me eight what does that
actually mean for me in relation to this
class
i'm number one i'm above average for the
height which is just
it's pretty funny it's actually probably
higher but whatever i'm just going to
put myself as a beverage i'm above
average not just i am above average it
tells me how much i am above average
does that make sense right and of course
if you are less than 170 if you say 164
you're gonna get a negative value so
that tells you you're below average and
how much right so what this is is the
difference from the mean this is what
this signifies right
how far am i from the mean and am i
above or below this is really important
um i'm saying difference from the mean
it really should be differences from
means but you get the idea it's just for
each different variable make sense
okay
so we've got the numerator now we are
adding up
a product there's a multiplication here
that is the combination of the
differences from the mean in other words
the further you are away from the mean
the bigger this numerator is going to be
and you're going to add up a bunch of
these things are you following so far
okay do you see how working out these
values is going to help us work out well
you've got all of these data points and
you're going to work out these distances
from the mean if your correlation
coefficient is
low
that means things don't they don't go
close to where this is right does that
make sense if your correlation
coefficient is close to one that means
everything is skewing very close to the
line okay you see how what we calculated
on our numerator is going to help me
does that make sense
okay now again you don't need to know
like the technical details you just need
to get a rough idea